dans le contexte déjà tendu de la crise
sanitaire une perspective qui inquiète
les milieux économiques le retour de
l'inflation pour l'instant mesurer la
hausse des prix semble s'installer à la
faveur de la flambée des cours de
matières premières et alors que les
banques centrales continuent de faire
tourner leur planche à billets alors
dans quelle mesure cette passion
naissante est elle une menace pour notre
pouvoir d'achat
allons-nous connaître un emballement
comparable à celui des années 70 c'est
l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir
jacques sapir
bonsoir c'est fait mais sans jacques
sommes nous vraiment à la veille d'une
forte poussée d'inflation comme certains
en tout cas le craignent alors c'est
tout à fait normal que les gens
craignent l'inflation
parce que s'il y avait une inflation
maintenant alors que les revenus sont
absolument jeunes et ça pourrait avoir
des conséquences tout à fait grave
mais si on en croit les chiffres de
l'insee il n'y a pas de réel redémarrage
de l'inflation est en tous les cas il
n'y a pas de problème à court terme même
si il y a à l'évidence un problème lié
lui à la question des matières premières
et donc ça veut dire que sur la question
de l'inflation
et bien tout n'est pas aussi simple
qu'il y paraît alors chacun commençons
par le commencement si j'ose dire que
disent les chiffres de l'inflation
bon si on prend les chiffres de l'insee
on voit tout de suite que le taux
d'inflation en france n'a jamais été
aussi bas on était au début des années
1990 autour de 2 3%
on est tombé sauf un petit pic
d'inflation en 2018 on est tombé en
dessous de 1%
donc on voit bien là qu'il n'y a pas de
problème immédiat en tous les cas y
envoyer qui a pas de tendance à la
remontée de l'inflation même si et ça
c'est un point qu'il faut qu'il faut
bien regarder il y a
depuis quelques mois une petite tendance
à la remontée de l'inflation
alors pourquoi cette crainte diffuse
alors il faut savoir que quand on parle
de l'inflation et quand l'insee parle de
l'inflation à l'analyse diverses choses
il ya évidemment l'indicé des prix à la
consommation c'est ce qu'on appelle
comme globalement à l'inflation
et puis il ya un autre indice qu'on
appelle l'inflation sous jacente
ce sont les prix des matières premières
alors on le voit aussi sur ce graphique
il y à une baisse globale de l' indice
des prix à la consommation et de
l'inflation sous jacente
sauf que depuis la fin du quatrième
trimestre et avec les premiers mois de
l'année et bien l'inflation sous-jacente
qui est cette courbe rouge qu'on voit à
côté des courbes bleus et des courbes
jaune et bien cette courbe rouge
elle est en train de remonter et cette
inflation sous jacente il faut le savoir
c'est essentiellement les matières
premières et le pétrole alors justement
jacques à quoi est due cette hausse des
matières premières en particulier comme
vous le livre des cours du pétrole
alors pour ce qui concerne le pétrole on
est dans une situation qui est quand
même très intéressante
rappelez vous il ya un an au mois de
mars 2020 on avait fait une émission où
on parlait des prix négatifs du pétrole
le pétrole était au plus bas
il a remonté c'est en partie normale
mais il a remonté très vite il a été en
moyenne autour de 54 dollars au mois de
janvier soit il sera probablement 60
dollars au mois de février et il ya des
analystes qui disent qu'ils pourraient
atteindre jusqu'à 75 dollars d'ici la
fin de l'année qu'est ce qui se passe
mais il se passe deux choses d'une part
on a des pays qui ont redémarré 1
la chine a redémarré les pays qui sont
autour de la chine la corée taïwan le
vietnam états ont redémarré donc qui dit
redémarrage économique dit besoin
d'énergie besoin de pétrole
d'un autre côté les pays producteurs eux
ont beaucoup baissé leur production à
cause de la crise qu'on a connus avant
même les effets de la crise sanitaire
cette crise du pétrole que l'on a connu
au mois de mars de l'année dernière et
il
ont maintenu d'une certaine manière les
contraintes sur la production alors
ajoutons à cela évidemment la vague de
froid qui a touché les états unis le
texas et de dakota qui sont deux zones
importantes de production et donc on a
aujourd'hui un déséquilibre important
entre eux
la demande pour le pétrole et la
production et c'est pour cela que les
prix sont en train d'augmenter
déjà que ce phénomène est ce qu'il est
limité au marché du pétrole
non justement et c'est quelque chose
d'assez important on voit que l'ensemble
des prix des matières premières est en
train d'augmenter alors on voit là aussi
sur ce graphique que savaient chuté avec
la crise sanitaire mais que là ça
remonte et ça remonte de manière
particulièrement important qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
eh ben ça veut dire qu'il y à des
pénuries alors on sait qu'il ya des
pénuries sur les matières premières
mais ce qui est encore plus intéressant
il faut savoir qu'il y a désormais des
pénuries sur des biens manufacturés les
microprocesseurs et ça ça tout de suite
des conséquences extrêmement importante
pour la production des voitures pour la
production d automobiles
c'est ce qui va d'ailleurs fait monter
d'une certaine manière le prix des
automobiles
mais il n'ya pas que ça il y a les
matières plastiques les produits en
plastique qui sert par exemple pour
l'emballage des médicaments pour leur
part la vis des vaccins
justement donc globalement c'est tout ce
qu'il y a en amont de la production
industrielle qui est en train
aujourd'hui de connaître des hausses de
prix importants et comme les français
consomment et ça c'est naturel
beaucoup de produits manufacturés et
bien il va y avoir nécessairement un
impact de cette hausse des prix est la
question qu'on peut se poser pourquoi de
tel désordre alors là encore il faut
revenir un petit peu au contexte général
on a des pays comme je les dis qu'ils
ont redémarré
c'est effectivement les qu'il a dit et
les pétitions au tour de la chine
à côté de ça on à l'europe qui
globalement n'a pas encore redémarré
la france insiste anne et on le voit là
sur l' indice de la production
industrielle nous sommes encore au début
de l'année 2000 21 nettement en dessous
du niveau que l'on avait atteint à la
fin de l'année 2019 bien mais même en
europe
on a des pays où l'activité est en train
de redémarrer plus vite qu'en france et
plus vite que dans le reste de l'europe
c'est par exemple le cas de l'italie et
c'est le cas de l'espagne et dans ces
deux pays
les producteurs industriels commencent à
se plaindre justement de cette pénurie
de matières premières du fait que ben
ils sont obligés d'augmenter leurs prix
pour attirer la production vers eux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que globalement on est dans une
situation où avec le redémarrage de
l'activité économique
alors que la production globale n'a pas
encore surmonté les effets de la crise
eh bien on va avoir des tensions
relativement importante et ces tensions
importantes vont provoquer une hausse
des prix alors jane dans quelle mesure
c'était notre question de départ est ce
que c'est une menace pour notre pouvoir
d'achat
quelles conséquences concrètes pour les
consommateurs que nous sommes
alors oui ça va avoir des conséquences
bien sûr ça ne va pas être des
conséquences dramatiques
vous aviez parlé en introduction de la
situation des années 70 on ne sera
jamais dans cette situation si vous
voulez on va pas retrouver une inflation
à deux chiffres ce qu'on avait connu au
début même des des années 80 par contre
il n'est pas du tout impossible que l'on
est en 2021
un taux d'inflation de l'ordre de 2% ce
qui aurait des conséquences parce que je
le rappelle les revenus son rôle tirent
relativement gelés et puis plus
particulièrement il y à ce problème par
exemple du prix des matières premières
et du prix des carburants
rappelons-nous le mouvement des gilets
jaunes il a été provoqué par une hausse
du prix des carburants
donc il va falloir surveiller de manière
tellement précises cette situation et
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation où avec la baisse de la
productivité qui est le résultat tout
simplement des mesures sanitaires qui
sont prises dans nombre d'entreprises
eh bien on va avoir je dirais des
goulets d'étranglement au niveau des
approvisionnements et c'est goulets
d'étranglement touré pendant cette année
provoqué une hausse des prix en
particulier sur les produits
manufacturés et bien merci jacques pour
cet éclairage qui donne comme toujours à
réfléchir merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine